hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey
we're gonna watch the trailer for the
Paul Rudd TV show living with Paul Rudd
instead with yourself living with
yourself Netflix series I'm excited to
check this out Paul Rudd coos a TV show
his movie career what's he done lately
yeah guys since the TV show must shout
this out
just check out our patreon page over
there we do weekly q and A's and we do
TV show reaction stream alongs for many
shows where you could sink up those are
Cobra Kai season two haunting of Hill
House season one Gotham stranger thing
season three agents of shield and there
are several shows where we do reaction
highlights included as well as the
option to do a stream along those are
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia movie
included as well Death Note Code Geass
one punch man hunter hunter and super
natural anywho
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you seriously jealous
unless you learned it since yesterday
morning you don't
- no please - saw some guns Oh No
[Music]
[Music]
was the same one you mean mr. hi
you should pick up a book sometime it's
like an evil version of multiplicity
yeah like that Rick and Morty episode
where they go to the spa to get their
toxic sides removed and then there are
functional sides and the toxic sides you
know as two separate characters I do
know that exactly like well this looks
like a fun show I'm not sure if I do a
reaction to it this is the kind of show
I would definitely probably binge watch
on a weekend it almost reminded me of
friends from college and its temperament
of humor in a way okay well you know
because like friends from college has
that nothing is very light-hearted
everything is dysfunctional yeah yeah
well I feel like this is gonna go down
of them significantly darker path than
that ship that's right oh yeah I mean it
looks like that cloten Paul Rudd is
gonna want to try to take over not clone
original Paul Rudd as the journey
progresses like they were hinting and a
lot of violence to come yeah definitely
I mean I think the trailer did a really
good job at selling me on ok this kind
of feels like a Judd Apatow movie you
know like in the beginning part of this
yeah I was thinking of this is 40 when I
was watching it yeah ok yeah I've seen
Paul Rowe do this role before dude
middle-aged not happy with his life
takes it out with a lot of sarcasm I've
seen that done and then when it had you
know the hook of it revealed I was like
okay who's gonna be like some weird
slice of life sci-fi oh no it's gonna be
like a weird thriller actually yeah I
like those kind of clone tails any you
have seen many shows include that kind
of clone tail actually been watching
Gotham season 3 recently and that's in
there as well and then I've seen so many
classic clone movies yeah and this feels
like a different take of it because of
the many explorations you could do with
it it's not just some temporary gimmick
it is like a focus and it's not going
for like big high thrills movie concepts
it seems like you can actually take the
time to have identity exploration
throughout the whole course of a season
while including some of that classic
this from a guy who like produced the
Daily Show and stuff the creator of this
okay okay and then you know yeah Paul
Rudd's comedic Sensibility is being
infused as well and all that political
humor yeah definitely I also really like
when actors give themselves the
challenge of playing to people yeah you
know Gemini man challenge of watching
actors do that because they don't really
have anyone to play off of and a lot of
times when you're doing a scene so much
of how you're doing your delivery is
based off of how you're reacting and
feeling and receiving when your partner
is giving you and he just has to do it
all purely off imagination so it's a fun
exercise for VFX artists and it's a fun
exercise for editors as well because
they're taking multiple different takes
and you're trying to make it mesh and
flow well yeah I would love to be a fly
on the wall for that because I have to
imagine that part of the time you're
working with a stand-in you know for the
parts where they're actually doing over
the shoulders or whatever but yeah in
certain moments to have to imagine not
only something outside of your own
reality but also that's another version
of you has to be sort of an
interestingly trippy thing to do because
you almost have to develop two
characters as an actor yeah this also
looks like the kind of show that would
put me on edge yes well yeah because I'm
sure it's going to be a lot less sci-fi
in its overall themes you know yeah
probably going to have or at least one
would hope it has some poignant things
to say about the duality of human nature
yeah it feels a little bit like a
Charlie Kaufman Show just a little bit
osmond into Apatow yeah it's not as like
trippy weird at least that's what the
trailer is not communicating that to me
yeah the sci-fi looks very low to the
ground feel like as the clone is
starting to ruin his life because it's
gonna be that thing where everything's
kind of great sort of wondrous I imagine
eventually it's gonna start taking this
very dark path and I think once the
clone really starts to intervene with
our main characters personal life I'm
just gonna be on edge and this is this
is how Netflix gets you with a binge
bottle that's when you start early oh
yeah I don't know what happens next I
always end it I don't have like these
complete episodes they just end in the
middle of a scene you're like I got it I
got a startup the next time you see the
next scene they're good at that and
they're also good at cutting these
series trailers to look like movies
because a lot of times from other
networks I'll see a trailer for a show
and I'm like okay yeah this looks like a
bunch of different moments from a bunch
of random places but this looks
contained in the way a movie does and I
have to imagine that in a way that
almost contributes to the binge ability
all right so I guess my question that I
have with watching the show says okay so
he's replaced clone is the one that
everyone seems to be loving yeah what's
he doing no it's like original Paul Rudd
doing this old are they like swapping in
and out once in a while or yeah that's
it just seems like he's stalking his
clone the whole time because I feel like
normally the flip scenario is there's a
clone and then the original Paul Rudd's
trying to live a life with his clones I
followed him right Yeah right that's it
usually what it is so I like the island
Alegre man yeah I like the twist on this
that like the clone has just replaced
him he's kind of just watching this
happen yeah it's his happy functional
Paul Rudd has replaced yeah sad
dysfunctional but what is sad
dysfunctional Paul Rudd doing the whole
time yeah me wonder whether we're gonna
see this show in a sort of two plot
lines parallel kind of way or whether
it's going to hand off with the spa
treatment and then you know have
basically original Paul Rudd intervene
on their life and maybe they'll have
some kind of clandestine relationship or
something or some switch in and out I
imagine that happy Paul Rudd is probably
secretly gonna be a little evil unless
they want to make this like a whole this
reads more like limited series
miniseries to me than it does at the
moment read as like something they want
to keep for seasons on end because if it
is miniseries I'd imagine that happy
Paul wrote is really like well no I got
to get rid of the old one now maybe evil
but hey maybe because I mean
dysfunctional Paul Rudd's trying to like
axe him at the beginning so maybe if
functional Paul Rudd will come up with a
healthy solution to this problem well
guys are you excited to go check out
living with yourself make a comment down
below if you will be binging this you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell check us on
patreon for all those goodies that I
mentioned earlier and before I wrap this
up I would like to give a page in the
day shout-out to a man named Matt beer
Matt beer you dip in and out of our
lives like nobody's business
sometimes you're with us sometimes
you're not sometimes you're like hey I
gotta take a break and then you come
back and then you over pledge and the
over pledge is usually just okay with us
but then I worry about you man gon tie
this into living with yourself you know
Matt I mean the thing is you're gonna
start to loathe yourself if you don't
budget these things right and then
pretty soon you're gonna find yourself
clones swapped out with a better version
of you that you're gonna resent and then
you're probably gonna try and kill that
clone of yourself which will probably
open up a rift in space-time and kill
the both of you so chill out and just
learn to budget your patreon support
higher more MORE
that like this is all you should be
paying for it's the way to get to our
hearts man whoo and happiness it's all
about money you spending it I think we
did we did